bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions le nombre de cas repart à la
hausse au maroc
quelle est la situation exactement est
ce qu'elle est sous contrôle ou est-ce
que vous êtes inquiet et les sous
contrôle et nous sommes inquiets les
deux îles et ce contrôle du moment que
on a une augmentation une hausse des cas
mais on a les services de réanimation
qui ne sont pas surchargées on a oui
pour son délit qui sont didier okou vite
qu'ils sont occupés donc on a un système
de santé qui est toujours performant il
peut accueillir donc plus de cas qu'on
n'espère pas avoir mais nous sommes
inquiets parce que quand on voit
justement cette cinétique cette vitesse
avec laquelle le nombre de cas augmente
et surtout un relâchement de la part de
la population
cette période estivale et donc c'est ce
qu'on craint avec le d'état de l'été les
vacances et donc on craint on est nous
sommes inquiets pour les semaines à
venir
30 % de la population est totalement
vacciner est ce que c'est suffisant
c'est suffisant pour absorber le sort qu
en cas de recrudescence
ce n'est pas suffisant pour protéger la
population ce n'est pas suffisant pour
éviter les mesures restrictives ce n'est
pas suffisant pour éviter des fermetures
même localiser et à 30 % de population
vaccinée complètement vaccinés au maroc
c'est une bonne chose du moment que il
faut ajouter un autre paramètre c'est
que la population à l'occasion du
population jeune donc avec avec 30% de
la population qui est doublement
vacciner nous sommes déjà à nous avons
déjà vaccinés les plus de 40 ans à 80 4
25% à partir de 40 ans c'est dire que
ces groupes d'âge qui sont les plus
vulnérables les plus à risque dans
l'est-var les animations et de faire des
décès
85 % de cette population est déjà
protégée mais ce n'est pas suffisant il
ne ce n'est jamais assez pour éviter
plus de décès ce n'est jamais assez pour
éviter des drames et ce n'est jamais
assez pour éviter des ddd des mesures
restrictives
ce n'est jamais assez pour éviter à la
population de se retrouver privé de sa
liberté de circuler de vivre et de
2 bien sûr de profiter des vacances
comment se positionnent les marocains
vis-à-vis de la vaccination et les y
sont favorables ou moins je pense sûr je
pense surtout à cette catégorie d'âge
des plus jeunes qui ne sont pas encore à
vacciner comme vous comme vous ne l'avez
dit on sait qu'en france parle beaucoup
de l'extension du pass à lithaire la
vaccination obligatoire pour pour les
soignants quelle est la situation de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée au maroc
il faut dire que la descente à ce qui a
été fait un sondage après sondage
africains sur ospina africa avant la
vaccination dans le maroc et qui
démontrait que omar konaré 80% de
d'intention de se faire vacciner
c'est le même temps qu'il y avait aux
états unis c'est le double de ce qu'il y
avait en france aux français et 40 %
donc pour les l'intention de se faire
vacciner il y avait cette attention
je rappelle également que pour le maroc
généralement les marocains n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas de problème avec
vaccination pour la vaccination des
enfants on atteint 96% 98% de protection
de vaccination si les enfants et bien
sûr les enfants ne vont pas au centre de
santé se faire vacciner tout seul ce
sont les paroles leurs parents qu'ils
amènent donc il n'y a pas un problème
phénomène des états où l'accident
ceci dit avec le colisée avec toutes ces
crises sanitaires il y avait ceux
complotisme il y avait quelques news
mais quand je vois que 80 % contre 25 %
de la population de 40 ans et plus s'est
fait vacciner quand je vois que à chaque
fois qu'il y ait un intérêt un avion qui
atterrit sur casablanca avec une
cargaison et qu'on élargit la compo de
vaccination mais c'est tout de suite
les stocks sont épuisés je pense qu'il
ya une bonne dose de vaccination de la
population
ceci dit bien sûr aux forces à force de
vacciner plus les visiteurs sont les
derniers donc aaa touchés et donc
certainement un jour ou l'autre on va
tomber sur qu'on sera amené à faire face
à ce problème d'hésitation mais d'une
manière marginale marginal sur le plan
statistique
mais pour réparer rédac arrête car a dit
qu'ils venaient pontdémé je pense même
ce taux marginal ils font le vaincre
sur l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé cet après midi il ya une forte
probabilité de voir des variants jeu si
possiblement plus dangereux c'est quand
même assez inquiétant est ce qu'un jour
cette pandémie elle va prendre fin on
n'en voit pas le bout 1
djillali annane le chef de réanimation
de l'hôpital raymond poincaré à garches
en région parisienne a dit en mars que
ça durera qui répondait mille durera 10
en une décennie
c'est votre analyse également le virus
il continuera à circuler certainement on
aura besoin de faire des rappels de
vaccination ne serait ce que pour
peut-être ne serait ce que pour les
populations les plus fragiles peut-être
peut-être c'est pour tout le monde après
le shaq une chaque concert deux ans sur
trois ans est pas mais je pense avec
l'appoint daily je pense qu'on peut
atteindre inimités collectif entre
guillemets c'est à dire prince est que
cette pandémie
après fin mais on a un problème
premièrement de distribution de
production des vaccins qui n'est pas
suffisante il ya problème de brevet bien
sûr deuxièmement il ya un problème d'
injustice vaccinale il ya des billons
vaccin tout le monde on va t'il des
enfants de 12 ans il ya des dp world et
70 à 65 ans 81 ans qui ne sont pas
encore vaccinés ont reçu aucune dose et
donc ne veut continuer de circuler
librement dans certains pays et il va
faire et des méthodes et d'imitations et
d aider des variantes et les variances
est de plus en plus grave parce que
c'est très sain parce que c'est une
c'est une course entre contre entre des
variants il y a un espoir pour faire
pour pour pour toucher la fin de cette
pandémie
il faut vacciner le plus vite possible
le vaccin a montré la radiation montré
son efficacité dont le freinage de la
transmission des virus et l'a montré
l'étude récente qui est montré que la
vaccination freine aussi l'apparition
des mutations la nationale 10 mutation
mais aussi qu on doit utiliser des
mesures qu'on a sous la main
ce sont les mesures barrières de cette
façon au freiner
on peut freiner la transmission et on
freine la transmission en frêne
l'apparition des mutations et lava
l'apparition des variants donc il faut
que jouer sur les 2 la vaccination la
vaccination mais aussi le respect strict
des mesures barrières pour pouvoir s'en
sortir dans les mois à venir
merci sayed hamdi d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du syndicat national de
médecine générale au maroc c